hey what's up everybody it is september
10th 2021
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message we are now roughly four
and a half days away
from the recall of gavin newsom i'm
psyched
i think i was fired up yesterday people
said dave you're normally calm you're an
even keeled guy you helped keep me sane
you were fired up yesterday well i'm
fired up today we'll see which way i can
channel the energy and guys look at this
shirt have you ever
seen
a better looking shirt in your life
recall newsome
and you know with the picture of a man
that the los angeles times calls the
black face of white supremacy so will
youtube stop this stream will they
delete my channel will they ban me and
demonetize me for having a white
supremacist t-shirt on the show we shall
find out i'll also get back to the la
times in just a minute there is a ton
going on unfortunately we're going to
have to talk a bit about kovid and these
mandates because basically all hell
broke loose yesterday like if you think
things have been bad with government
overreach and just the endless extension
of the state into every part of your
life well biden or the shell that biden
is with whoever's pulling the strings
they just ramped up just getting
involved in every single part of your
life with these mandates that are going
to go through the federal government
they're going to go through companies
with more than 100 employees which of
course is completely arbitrary and
that's just the first step before they
get to companies that were much smaller
and much more that and by the way we've
got video of of course biden saying he'd
never do it and pelosi saying he'd never
do it etc etc so that's story number one
story number two we're gonna get you
caught up on everything uh recall
related uh i'm gonna talk more about the
la times they have written not only that
larry elder is the black face of white
supremacy but they have a couple other
headlines about larry elder about that
woman the white woman in the monkey
mask who threw the egg at him and the
way they framed the story actually made
it sound like larry elder was being the
violent one we'll juxtapose a couple
headlines for you and then i've just got
like three videos of aoc being an idiot
and we'll just we'll just play him quick
and then after the show today we're
going to vote he's going to vote i'm
going to vote this guy's going to vote
david's going to vote we're all going to
vote and we're going to show up and vote
in person i know gavin newsom i know you
don't want people to vote in person but
we are gonna vote in person oh and i
should mention that in the larry elder
segment that we're gonna do the recall
segment segment number two uh we're also
gonna cover the video that we put up
yesterday i had rose mcgowan on rose
mcgowan is the actress who basically
took down harvey weinstein right like
she was the hero of the feminists for
fighting the patriarchy stopping this
horrific serial rapist etc etc well on
the show yesterday
she claimed that she met with
the wife of gavin newsom gavin newsom's
current wife jennifer newsom on behalf
of david boyes who was harvey
weinstein's lawyer to see what they
could do
to get rose to go away
basically pay her off so that the harvey
weinstein story wouldn't happen this was
about three months before the weinstein
story broke that is an incredible
accusation
rose says she has the receipts on it i
may or may not have seen such receipts
and uh nobody in the mainstream media is
picking up it was picked up of course by
the blaze and the daily wire and
post-millennial real clear politics
actually i just saw that brett bear over
at fox news retweeted it but one of the
sick twisted
ways that society is crumbling right now
is that the media does not do their job
when it doesn't fit their narrative they
really want newsome to be in power right
that's why obama's doing ads and
kamalas here and and they're sending you
know aoc is doing videos and everything
else so they don't care about women in
this case when the wife of the governor
is trying to pay off a rape victim of
harvey weinstein can't get that to get
to main stream yet so we're going to
keep pushing it and i'm i'm doing my
best on twitter we'll anyway we'll get
to all that before we get to any of this
stuff guys i want to talk to you about
marley spoon you know now that i'm back
on the grid it's time to get back to
normal normal and that means back to
busy i'm looking forward to simplifying
my kitchen routine with martha stewart
and marley spoon america's best tasting
meal kit sign up today with code reuben
and get 100 bucks off your first four
boxes martha stewart and marley spoon
deliver quick and convenient meals
designed by chefs to be ready in about
30 minutes the ready-to-heat meals are
ready in under five minutes the
subscription is always flexible so you
can skip your skip or pause whenever you
want and orders can be customized every
week to suit tastes and special diets
whether you're looking for kid friendly
favorites like pizza and tacos
adventurous and flavorful dishes from
around the world or desserts breakfasts
or smoothies martha stewart and marley
spoon have got you covered you all know
i love to cook and pull out all the
stops but it's also nice sometimes to
have someone else put together
everything for you i was scrolling
through the menu online this morning and
there really are some great looking
dishes they've got this oktoberfest
smoked cheddar currywurst that looks
incredible
michael over here was drooling he was
drooling over the harissa honey roasted
eggplant stop drooling michael and
they've got this german sunken apple
cake with whipped sour cream just to top
it all off and those are just some of my
options for this week so if you're like
me and tired of rush meals and boring
dinners let martha stewart and marley
spoon change that go to marthaspoon.com
and use promo code ruben to get 100
bucks off your first order that's 100
bucks of free food just for using promo
code reuben it's a game changer
everything's delicious everything's
ready fast and everybody including my
own crew apparently wants to return for
seconds check them out at
marleyspoon.com and now back to me
little insider knowledge for you guys by
the way uh little known fact i actually
was a pa a production assistant on
martha stewart's talk show when she got
out of jail remember she had that talk
show for about 10 years and for about uh
two seasons i was a pa on that show i
once was in a room alone with martha
stewart and she had me adjust her chair
so there you go
okay let's talk
important stuff you know
all right let's talk about vaccines and
the mandates and everything else there's
a lot
of craziness going on so first i want to
show you this video of a reporter asking
jen
saki miss i could not tell the truth if
my life depended on it
asking her whether the administration
has authority to force private companies
to mandate
vaccines and my god i think she actually
said something she believes here take a
look to use your word how bold is the
president willing to be as far as the
private sector is concerned in the
vaccine the mandate area even if they
don't have
federal contracts can the department of
labor or anybody else compel
major employers
the large employers to force the vaccine
mandates on their employees
yes stay tuned more to come this
afternoon go ahead
so i don't know if that's true that
biden actually has the constitutional
power to do it but at least she's being
honest like yes we're going to do it
we're going to force companies to do it
and as we're going to get to momentarily
they now are forcing companies with over
100 employees to do it or at least
they're trying to force companies with
over a hundred employees to force
everyone to get vaccinated i just want
to say to you two sitting in this room
right now that um you know i know i'm a
benevolent leader around here but i'm
never going to force you to be injected
with anything to work here
so you're welcome uh yeah i got a thumbs
up that's nice um so that's one thing so
yes she says and she smiles when she
says it because these people really love
power and if you don't think they love
power well here's uh old joe
talking about how he plans to use power
and all school officials trying to do
the right thing by our children
i'll always be on your side
let me be blunt
my plan also takes on elected officials
in states that are undermining you
and these life-saving actions
right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe in a pandemic while
their governor
picks a fight with them
and even threatens their salaries or
their jobs
talk about bullying in schools
if they'll not help if these governors
won't help speak the pandemic
i'll use my power as president to get
them out of the way
i will use my power as president to get
them out of the way does that sound like
the president of the united states at
least the united states that i used to
know or does that sound like a dictator
i will use my power as president to get
them out of the way now i do want to
give credit where credit is due you know
i always try to do that joe actually was
able to read the teleprompter there he
obviously has dementia and we all know
it and there's a huge problem with his
cognitive abilities but he did read that
one without mumbling and stuttering over
it so i will give him credit for that
but that line i'll use my powers
president get them out of the way is
probably the most dangerous thing i've
ever heard a president say
in my lifetime
please show me where donald trump said
something that dangerous that the
federal government will impede on the
state's rights to make decisions for
themselves by the way that is
unconstitutional we have something here
called the federalist system right and
each state is supposed to make the rules
for itself now maybe none of this works
anymore right like maybe that's where
we're at that the constitution is a
piece of paper that we're supposed to be
governed by the bill of rights are a
series of laws to protect us and protect
our god-given rights but maybe they just
sit on paper and now the machine the
evil machine that is this administration
and that's the only way i can describe
it has decided we're not going to abide
by any of those things and there's
obviously no one in the media that's
going to stand up against them the media
will actually cheer it on
uh and there's really no one politically
i mean there's a couple there's a couple
decent people right so i think it was
can we get the number on this i think
around 14 or 17 republican governors
said they're going to stand up against
this um but what does biden mean are you
going to send in federal troops to take
over these states
maybe maybe i mean does that sound crazy
what what would be too crazy for this
administration i don't think there's
anything that would be too crazy for
this administration at this point we'll
get you the exact number on the
republicans uh the republican governors
who said they're not going to abide by
this by the way there's also a
spectacular video by jeremy boring of
the daily wire they do have over 100
employees i have two companies we don't
have over 100 yet
but they do have over 100 and he said he
will not
force anyone that works for him to get
the vaccine he said he himself is
vaccinated and that he believes in
vaccines but he's just not going to do
it and they're looking into all the the
legal recourse i believe the blaze is
doing the exact same thing
and
among some of the states that are
threatening to fight back texas missouri
georgia i have no doubt that desantis in
florida but i think that i think that
about 17 governors if i'm not mistaken
now if you think all of that is nuts
well let's just look at some video from
some of the democrats saying that they
would never require anyone to be
vaccinated here's skeletor-like nancy
pelosi
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory but
there will be no nationwide mandate i
was referring to mandates by private
institutions and portions of the federal
government there will be no federal
mandate one that's not the role of the
federal government i don't think you'll
ever see a mandating of vaccine
particularly for the general public but
you would never mandate at least i do
not think you would
uh i'd be pretty uh surprised if you
mandated it for any element of the
general public
all right sorry about that we got the
the clips backwards there uh so fauci
biden sake
and the head of the cdc all saying that
we'll never have federal mass mandates
now do we have the pelosi one we've got
the pelosi art here's nancy pelosi
so here's the thing we are we cannot
require someone to be vaccinated that's
just not what we can do
it is a matter of privacy to know who is
or who isn't
we cannot require someone to be
vaccinated that's what she said months
ago and she talks about privacy and we
do have some privacy laws in the united
states so again i don't know that any of
the laws work i don't know that any of
it matters anymore i don't know that
there's enough of us that will stand up
i'm doing what i can a few other people
are um but these are their words so
nancy so if we had journalists right if
we had journalists and not journalists
what would somebody be doing next time
they saw nancy pelosi at the ice cream
store or getting a haircut what they
would say to her is nancy nancy you know
a few months ago you said that we cannot
force people to be vaccinated you didn't
say we should not or i don't want to you
said we cannot that implies that there's
laws that allow for medical privacy and
it's and my body my choice and people
want to make decisions for themselves
and their family so what changed because
old dementia joe decided to have this
federal mass mandate for all federal
employees and get this one i mean this
is just the
ridiculousness if you don't think that
these people are utter clowns and abject
buffoons
they are mandating vaccines to all
federal employees which i think is
something like we get the number how
many federal employees i think is around
2 million or so but they are exempting
the postal workers there's about 650 000
postal workers i think so that everyone
has to do it except we're putting an
exemption on the postal workers
guys the postal workers are the ones who
come to everybody's house who touch all
your stuff and then you pick it up
so
i'm not
2.1 million federal workers and about
650 000 post workers so it's all just
absolutely nonsensical uh by the way
this made me all think all the way back
to july and i know none of us have
memories anymore but something you know
i was off the grid for a month so my
memory has been a little sharper lately
i've been able to reorganize things in
my brain and i thought wait a minute
wait a minute wasn't there some guy
named dave rubin who got suspended on
twitter right before i went off the grid
some real right-wing freedom-loving
maniac because he said something about
um oncoming federal mass mandates and
then you're not going to believe this we
found this screenshot this is this is
nuts so some guy i don't know who this
is dave rubin at ruben report whatever
the hell that is and he said they want a
federal vaccine mandate for vaccines
which are clearly not working as
promised just weeks ago people are
getting and transmitting kovid despite
the facts plus now they are preparing us
for booster shots a sane society would
take pause we do not live in a sane
society you're not going to believe this
again i have no idea who this nut bag is
but he got suspended for about 24 hours
on twitter for that for saying that a
federal mass mandate is coming for
saying that vaccines aren't working as
promised those things are obviously true
uh and that you know we're going to need
more booster shots according to these
people and that's happening right now uh
twitter did from what i understand unban
him
and said it was an error but you know a
guy like that should not in my opinion
should not be allowed to be on social
media because you know you can't be
ahead of the curve you know what i mean
like you gotta fall in line man you
can't just say the truth and then just
wait around
i don't like that guy can we let's find
out who he is and send him a strongly
worded letter
all right guys before we move to story
number two i want to talk to you about
uprising food you know you all know how
much i love food i just told you a
little bit about it a moment ago and for
those of you who've been tuning into my
show over the past couple years you know
that i've had various guests who've
talked all about how our food system is
fundamentally broken and making us sick
at scale well fortunately the people at
uprising food are fixing that uprising's
mission is to liberate all of us from a
broken food system that's stealing our
health they have cracked the code on
healthy bread you simply can't find
something this healthy that tastes this
good that's this fresh i received the
starter bundle bundler sampler and
please don't make me choose between the
sea salt chips and the rye chips i can't
do it i have them they're good i'm just
so happy to have both with these two net
carbs per serving two grams of protein
and nine grams of fiber uprising food
covers paleo to clean keto to simple low
carb high fiber to dairy free to grain
free lifestyles all uprising products
are baked with real superfood
ingredients almonds
mct oil apple cider apple cider vinegar
egg whites psyllium husk and olive oil
uprising has absolutely nailed the taste
factor on both of their sourdough s
cubes and the crunch factor on their
near newly launched freedom chips
there's a name which tastes like those
old school rye chips you dig
basically if you're a bio hacker and a
if a biohacker and a high-end farmer's
market baker had a baby it'd be these
uprising products go to uprisingfood.com
and use code ruben to get 10 off the
starter bundle it's kind of like a mini
trip to the grocery store minus all the
unhealthy distractions and they ship
directly to your door of course that's
uprisingfood.com and use my code ruben
for ten dollars off your first order and
now back to me okay let's talk about the
man on my shirt right here mr larry
elder he's getting a lot of momentum he
was on tucker carlson last night you
know obviously there was this ridiculous
incident with the with the
monkey woman
and the egg and it's like you don't want
anything like that to happen but at
least it did bring attention to his
campaign that's good obviously the
democrats are nervous because they're
bringing out the big guns
obama and kamala and i think biden is
doing something today supposedly and as
i said yesterday look if it's gavin
newsom barack obama and kamala harris
and now joe biden versus larry elder me
and scott baio
i like our chances we're going to be all
right
so first i want to show you these two
headlines this is this is just really
like if you want to see how perverse
really perverse and dishonest the
mainstream media is these are two of the
headlines from the los angeles times
this is the los angeles times the same
los angeles times who by the way as you
know said that larry elder is putting is
the black face uh on white supremacy
okay so look at these two headlines now
you all know what happened the other day
this crazy woman that you're seeing
there with the pink gorilla mask she
started screaming uh racist remarks and
cursing at larry and a whole bunch of
other people were saying really horrific
things at larry as he was just walking
through venice because venice has become
a drug den and a homeless encampment
basically uh so she's throwing a
negative she then assaulted one of the
um
one of the security guards and look how
they framed it
larry elder cuts short venice homeless
encampment tour after
hostile reception
and then look at the second one
now first off the first one hostile
reception the implication is that he's
getting a hostile reception like from
sane people right like like he got there
and he said something that then they
were hostile about um but these were
crazy drug addicts and maniacs but the
import what they're trying to do is
frame it is that he's somehow
controversial that that first one's not
terrible actually but i want to show you
the second one which is really just it's
just remarkable
lapd is investigating altercation
involving larry elder at venice homeless
encampment
what does that sound like to you if you
didn't know this story it sounds like
larry elder picked a fight probably with
a homeless person at a homeless
encampment that is so deeply dishonest
it's it's just it's pure
[ __ ]
bull [ __ ] that's what it is and the el
the the la times at this point is a
white supremacist newspaper i can only
deduce that between you know basically
calling him a white supremacist lying
about this violent attack not saying
that you know what where are all their
op-eds about the racist base of the
democratic party that's throwing eggs
and attacking a black candidate you know
where's all of that so i guess the la
times is a white supremacist newspaper
there's sort of no way around it
that being said i still am feeling good
about what's happening with the recall
and i get it you know i really want to
make this point clear well two points
here actually first off i get it the
deck is stacked against us this is this
is largely a democratic state and modern
liberals no matter how many times you
whack them in the head with reality uh
it's very hard for them to go oh all of
the reasons the state sucks the high
taxes high regulation bad schools bad
roads homelessness drug use etc it's
it's hard to believe that that could
have anything to do with the way i've
been voting right uh this is like sort
of what i would say to bill maher if
he's ever brave enough to put me on the
show it's like you rail against all of
these things all day long you're a good
liberal right my good
my good liberal friends what happened to
my idw good liberals they've all gone
silent on everything that matters and i
do want to give a complete exception to
that on ben shapiro and jordan peterson
who have been as good as ever but the
liberals have just completely completely
collapsed um so let's uh also show you
because we're talking about the media
and larry elder here this this video
from yesterday now i know some of you
have seen this yesterday
but rose mcgowan was on the show rose
mcgowan is the girl who in effect
single-handedly took down harvey
weinstein she walked through the fire
said this man raped me it started
uncovering all of the other horrific
rapes and sexual assaults that harvey
weinstein did two years ago he was the
biggest bad guy in america right like
that was the thing it started the me too
movement
you know believe all women all of that
stuff well now rose mcgowan is coming
out and saying that gavin newsom's wife
jen newsom
three months before the harvey weinstein
story broke when they knew it was going
to break that she contacted rose on
behalf of harvey weinstein's lawyer
to see what could make the story go away
and she's saying she has receipts do you
think that maybe that's worthy of the
news covering it right now that the
california governor who's under recall
that his wife was shilling for harvey
weinstein to silence
someone who was sexually assaulted by
harvey weinstein like do you think that
maybe that's newsworthy maybe well first
in case you haven't seen it here's rose
jennifer seabold news him i think that
is her name yes she called me and she
set up a meeting with me to meet her
someone in brentwood and i actually went
and i got very like creeped out and i
saw her sitting where her sister meet
her and i looked at her and i i turned
around and went back into my car and
drove away she wanted to meet me she was
when is this when is this just this is
about uh six months before the new york
times article in weinstein that i set up
broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
theranost board member the
lawyer for
long time lawyer of hillary and bill and
clinton and weinstein
won david boyce so this woman i don't
know some blonde lady named with the
last name of newsome cold calls me and
it's like
david boyce wants to know what it would
take
to make you happy
six months before the weinstein story
what do it take to make you happy which
you took as for those that might be
playing along a little bit slowly
i i don't know because i don't know if
it would be fiscal remuneration i don't
know i like absolutely nothing would
make me happy
what would it take to make you happy
this guy was raping you for years raping
all kinds of people he's the most evil
man in america the entire system
uh tells you how awful he is you know he
should burn in hell blah blah blah
believe all women it started an actual
revolution in this country in some
respects uh but now that this story is
not being covered now i do want to
clarify two things here uh in that video
there she said uh six months before the
story broke she later clarified with me
yesterday after we taped the show that
it was three months before the new york
times ran the harvey weinstein story so
that's just it's not that important but
it's worth mentioning
and also if you watch the full interview
originally jennifer newsome wanted a
in-person meeting
with rose rose actually went saw her
sitting there and then didn't go and
then this was all done on a phone call
rose is saying she has receipts and i'm
not saying i haven't have not seen
receipts
but where are you media where are you
media or
gavin
jennifer come out and say she's a liar
is she a liar
where are you gav come on
speaking of liars i want to end the show
today uh with three videos from aoc and
i think i'm going to cover these in a
very special way just with one line each
because i'm going to let aoc the wonder
woman of intellectual genius i'm gonna
let her words stand on their own video
one
well i certainly don't think it's
healthy that exxon mobil lobbyists are
bragging about how many senators
democrat and republican that they get to
have spee on speed dial and enjoy
exclusive access to shaping the contours
of this quote-unquote bipartisan
infrastructure bill i don't think that
that's healthy at all i think the role
of dark money and
and the fossil fuel lobby is extremely
unhealthy for our democracy
but the fact of the matter is is that
we've got the people on on our side and
this is what we continue to say you know
they have money these lobbyists and
special interests have money but we've
got people the buildback better act has
popular support and even going above and
beyond that the green new deal has
popular support even among republicans
and independents and so what what people
i think are united behind is the
acknowledgment that climate change is
human caused that the burning of fossil
fuels and the continued construction of
fossil fuel infrastructure like what
we're seeing with line three in
minnesota must be confronted if we're
going to create a better future for
ourselves
yeah the green new deal has popular
support even among republicans and
independents aoc you're a liar
next when we talk about um
the law that was passed in texas we know
that anti-choice bills
are not about being pro-life because if
they were about being pro-life
then the republican party would support
frankly an agenda that helps
guaranteed health care that helps ensure
that people who do give birth that don't
have the resources uh to care for a
child can have that care for a child so
we know that none of this is about life
none of this is about supporting life
what this is about is controlling
women's bodies and controlling
people who are not cisgender men this is
about making sure that someone like me
as a woman or any menstruating person in
this country cannot make decisions over
their own body and people like governor
abbott and mitch mcconnell want to have
more control over over a woman's body
than that woman or that person has over
themselves and what what that shares in
uh in
you know what that shares with rape
culture is that sexual assault
is about the abuse of power and sexual
assault is about asserting control over
another person and the ease
with which these men seek to do that to
other people is atrocious
aoc in that video in case you weren't
playing paying attention called women
people who give birth then she called
them women and then she called them any
menstruating person
thus aoc you're a transphobic [ __ ] clip
three
yes now listen if you live in california
there's probably a ballot in your
mailbox on a recall election
please find that thing
vote no stick that sucker right back in
your mailbox because the options are
back
aoc just get the [ __ ] out of my state
you buffoon we don't want you here we
don't care what you think and we're
gonna do what we think is right but
because you are so
rabidly against a decent black man
becoming governor of the great state of
california the once great state i should
say uh you are a right-wing
racist white supremacist congratulations
aoc
guys part three of my interview with
tucker carlson and i promise you promise
you promise you this is tucker carlson
like you've never heard him before part
three is up right now on youtube went up
this morning the full episode of course
is up already absolutely ad-free at
rubinreport.locals.com
and guess where we're going now guys
we're going to vote that's right we are
going to vote will i get kicked out of
the polling station for wearing this
shirt i will bring i know there might be
some like rule about you can't wear a
pin or a shirt or a hat that's promoting
anyone so i'm gonna try to go like this
and then you know
if they say something to me i'll bring a
hoodie and i'll cover it up uh but i do
wanna say uh as i close the show that
i've never been more proud to vote for
someone as i will be when i walk into
that booth today larry is a good decent
man who as i said yesterday he doesn't
really want to be governor because he
doesn't want to be governor in that he
doesn't want to solve all your problems
he wants to be governor because this
thing is so
freaking broken because it's so
out of control
and you know it's very obvious to me
that america needs a massive shock to
the system if everything that i talked
about on the show day aoc is an idiot
the media is awful
all this covid stuff and mandates and
people that are now don't know what to
do because they don't want to lose their
jobs but they also don't want to get a
vaccine for whatever reason they don't
want to when they're young and healthy
or whatever it might be if all of this
seems horrible to you and it is horrible
like it really is it is
whether i can occasionally joke about it
or not like this is this is bad stuff
like the creep of socialism or communism
or just authoritarianism whatever you
want to call it it's here it's on our
shores it's been ushered in by the
liberals in the media it's it's it's
terrible it is here there's no doubt
about it but you know there's always
hope humans always have hope humans have
always been through bad things and
things have gotten better but at some
point enough of us have to say no i will
no longer participate
in this lie uh you know i think i
mentioned the other day that one of the
movies we watched
during uh
time off grid was cloud atlas and it's a
really interesting movie by the
wachowski brothers who did v for
vendetta and they did the matrix and a
whole bunch of other stuff and the line
the main line in the movie is i will not
be subjected to criminal abuse and it's
a theme throughout many decades and
hundred year periods actually thousand
year periods in the movie you have to
see the movie to fully understand what
i'm saying but it's in in essence is oh
the lie stops with me the lie stops with
me and lies are everywhere and
encroaching power is everywhere and we
need some hope that's the point like we
need something like i think a lot of
people are just like man everything is
collapsing all around us and you're kind
of right like i'm not going to sit here
and say you're not right but there is
hope and you know as goes california
goes the nation well then let's fix
california so please if you're in
california do the right thing and vote
yes
on the recall and then vote for larry
elder or at least vote yes on the recall
and then if you want to vote for
somebody else so be it um i think my
feelings about larry are clear
but imagine imagine if on tuesday just a
couple days from now imagine if it
happened imagine if it happened a blow
to the machine you know what i mean like
if it took a hit and then suddenly
people were like holy cow california
isn't on the endless descent to hell and
then other people in other states would
suddenly feel good and feel more
empowered and feel like oh i'm a decent
human being maybe there's something i
can do whether it's run for governor or
stand up at a school board or fight for
what i believe in however it is that i
can do it we just need a signal
and i really think that this situation
right now on tuesday is a signal and
maybe maybe it will be that on wednesday
i'm going to be pretty damn depressed
when i'm in this room maybe it will be
but that's not a reason not to fight so
please fight with me however you can
elect elder.com they need a couple bucks
to finish strong here unfortunately
politics is about money and trust me i
know i've talked to larry privately
enough like the idea of asking for money
is ridiculous and he doesn't want to do
it so i'll do it for him there you go
elect elder dot com and let's let's see
if we can get to something with a little
hope i have hope do you have hope um all
right have a good weekend everybody
we're gonna go you know maybe we'll do
some videos can we do some videos maybe
on the way or yeah all right so we'll do
some videos on the way i don't think
they're going to let us do videos at the
polling place but i'm i'm sorry and do
it guys recall this prick and let's get
larry elder to be the next governor of
california have a great weekend
everybody and if you want to play along
with food and music and all that stuff
reubenreport.locals.com